[Music]
last year the republicans handed gma
windfall of 150 million dollars
in their tax bill gm
could bring back money from overseas
they said they would do it and employ
people well they're bringing back money
from overseas but they're not employing
people
it seems like gm would rather build its
electric cars in china
rather than the united states
we are going to be looking at certain
subsidies
regarding electric cars and others
whether they should apply or not
well as that was going on at the white
house that very press briefing the
president was tweeting about general
motors saying this
very disappointed with general motors
and their ceo maribera for closing
plants in ohio
michigan and maryland nothing being
closed in mexico and china the u.s saved
general motors
and this is the thanks we get we are now
looking at cutting all gm subsidies
including for electric cars
general motors made a big china bet
years ago while they built plants there
and in mexico don't think that bed is
going to pay off
i am here to protect america's workers
if you look at
general motors stock it took a tumble
today just as that tweet was coming out
it recovered a bit
later in the day just a few minutes ago
the washington post released part of an
interview it did
in which the president says about not
being worried about a recession
i'm doing deals and i'm not being
accommodated by the fed
they're making a mistake because i have
a gut and my gut tells me more
sometimes than anybody else's brain can
ever tell me he really goes in this
interview
against the federal reserve chairman
jay powell he says so far i'm not even a
little bit happy with my selection of
jay not even a little bit
i'm not blaming anybody but i'm just
telling you i think the fed
is way off base with what they're doing
well let's bring in our panel jonah
goldberg senior editor at national
review
marla lyon national political
correspondent of national public radio
and katie pavlich news editor at
townhall.com
mark there are a lot of things the the
president does
tweets says that obviously don't track
with where other presidents
go attacking his fed chair
has been one of those right well many
presidents are frustrated by their fed
sure
whether they do something about it is
another matter so this is the most
frustrated he's been so far with jay pal
he wants easy money he doesn't want
interest rates to go up he doesn't want
the recovery to to end and that's he
sounds like that's what he's worried
about
does he have a case to make that the fed
is acting too fast
that is way above my pay grade i think
there are some people who
think they are but jay powell is trying
to follow in the very careful footsteps
of janet yellen and manage this so
there's not
inflation which hasn't been a problem
for a very long time because the fed has
gotten really good at that
but in terms of yanking subsidies from
general motors if you want to yank some
subsidies from everybody that's one
thing but to punish general motors
by taking away just their subsidies that
sounds like crony capitalism in reverse
just the
thing that republicans and conservatives
are supposed to hate more than anything
else
again not a traditional action by a
president going after or mentioning
specific companies you know uh in this
action in this way
yet again does he have a point about
u.s subsidies for a company that's
choosing to
close plants in the u.s and not close
them in china and mexico well president
trump's tweet today gave me flashbacks
of 2008 when he talks about
look we the america american people have
given gm and other companies a lot and
that goes back to the argument of
we should have never bailed out those
companies in the first place they should
have hit rock bottom
and come back on their own instead of
being propped up for years and
continuing to sell cars
that people don't want to buy which is
part of their problem here it is
inappropriate for
the federal government to go after any
singular company for not doing what they
want specifically but there is a huge
case to be made
generally about how certain subsidies
have been given to electric car makers
for cars that people aren't buying
and so we can make the argument that
look we shouldn't have bailed that gm in
the first place
that is coming home to roost now in a
way that conservatives and republicans
and other
economic factors predicted back when
this happened and here we are moving
forward with these jobs
going away in the u.s which is something
that president trump obviously doesn't
like because he campaigned on keeping
them here
the the gm vehicle is being discontinued
the president singled out
the chevy cruze but there are there are
others and the plants being
uh shut down uh big ones in ohio
michigan maryland actually two in
michigan but you know you can't take the
politics out of any of this jonah
they're looking at ohio saying wait a
second ohio
yeah no look i mean it's politically
embarrassing for the president who
had has been bragging about these plans
coming back i think he said it in a
rally last night i agree entirely with
katie about this though
um the reason why gm is closing these
specific plants is because people aren't
buying the
specific cars being sold in those plans
and
they're following in the footsteps of
ford a lot of these guys are getting out
of the passenger car market and going
into the light truck market
and i don't i didn't think barack obama
knew enough
how to manage a you know a huge economy
from the white house
um i don't know that donald trump's
instincts are any better i mean i'm one
of these friedrich hayek guys i think
you know you the market is supposed to
work this stuff out these guys are
making business decisions close
to the ground where they know how to
make them i'm all for getting rid of
these electric subsidies
for everybody for everybody for
everybody to do it as a punitive thing i
think it's a really bad idea
all right at the same time the market
went up today in part because of
hopes that some deal with china could be
worked out here's larry kudlow
there's a good possibility
that we can make a deal and he is open
to it
but on the other hand if these
conditions i mentioned a few moments ago
are not met not dealt with you know the
president has said
um look he's
perfectly happy to stand on his tariff
policies
so you're saying there's a chance uh
maura he's going to be he's a very
optimistic guy
he's going to meet with president xi on
the sidelines of the g20 in argentina
that's right
you know talking to administration
officials they do think that that china
wants to make a deal yes china wants to
make a deal but what
their the the u.s is asking china to do
is almost to give up its business model
they want they don't want any more
forced technology transfers they don't
want intellectual property theft they
don't want non-tariff barriers
that's the chinese business model china
would have to make deep
structural changes to satisfy the u.s
finally i want to turn one more topic
and this is the paul manafort uh
topic he's being accused of lying to
special counsel the plea deal
is up in the air as far as uh they're
saying he's totally uh
undermined it by lying uh then there's
the story katie and the the guardian
saying that manafort held secret talks
with julian assange of wikileaks
suggesting that he had some previous
knowledge uh prior knowledge before
these emails came out
manafort puts out a statement through
his team this story is totally false and
deliberately libelous
i have never met with julian assange or
anyone connected to him
i've never been contacted by anyone
connected to wikileaks either directly
or indirectly
i've never reached out to assange or
wikileaks on any matter
we are considering all legal options
against the guardian who did the story
who proceeded with this story even after
being notified by
representatives that it was false i mean
you can't get a more
stringent denial than that wikileaks
which doesn't have a ton of credibility
when it comes to telling the truth but
they also issued a similar denial
and the guardian walked back some of the
more
strict language in that story putting in
words like apparently and not
exactly following through with it being
a solid allegation that had some backing
the truth is we're not going to know
until robert mueller comes out with his
full report about what the exact
connections were but paul manafort has a
right to defend himself against these
accusations especially since
they're very serious and they have to do
with his plea deal we're talking about
somebody walking into an embassy
there are cameras everywhere you think
that he was there they could prove that
right i mean it should be able to
be filled with cameras and also he it is
one of the most monitored doorways in
the western world
and so the idea i i generally think that
paul manafort is a
really duplicitous terrible person and
he could be in a lot of trouble and he's
in big trouble
uh and i i don't trust wikileaks julian
assange either but the idea that there
aren't
multiple intelligence agencies
monitoring that door at all times to see
if julian assange is coming out with a
fake mustache and a trench coat
is kind of ludicrous and photos involved
with the story would have seemed as an
accompaniment to prove what the story
was saying
well we're still on mueller watch and
we'll see what happens and it could be
any day
after this election in mississippi one
would think now between now and
christmas
something's happening